Pete, this has been a really
fun whirlwind tour of
everything somebody would need
to start developing responsibly.
>> It has.
We've learned to the basics of
well-sized elements for mobile.
Using breakpoints and
media queries, to change the page
layout for different devices.
Common responsive design patterns, and
we've gone into some advance techniques,
like minor breakpoints.
At this point,
you've got all the tools and
concepts you need to build
amazing responsive sites.
>> You know, and I think it's fair to
say that, all you need now, is an idea
for a site, and some time to let your
content inform your responsive design.
>> Go build something awesome.
Good luck, and have fun.